que patrick badauds expatriés français
vivant à vienne depuis maintenant près
de 15 ans bonsoir patrick et amado merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur la france
d'avoir accepté de nous parler de cette
situation
autrichienne qui on doit bien lire non
fait parfois un petit peu en ville la
situation semble être en tout cas moins
pire si j'ose dire en autriche 2 104
morts pour le bilan sur vingt huit 28
millions d'habitants
selon vous qui connaissez les deux pays
pourquoi les autrichiens s'en sortent
mieux que nous ben on doit d'abord donc
je pense que l'autriche a réagi très
vite à la situation
donc en prenant très rapidement les
mesures qui s'imposaient et donc ce
qu'on a pu constater aussi c'est que
dans l'ensemble la population semble
bien respecter les mesures de
confinement et les restrictions qui ont
été prescrites et donc bon en fait ces
mesures sont apparus aussi à un moment
en fait tous les les chiffres de
l'infection n'était pas encore prêt très
important en fait alors c'est vrai que
on dit souvent oui d'autriche qui a
réagi plus vite d'ailleurs c'est ce que
dit le chancelier courte ça nous avons
nagé plus vite plus drastiquement que
d'autres pays dans le même temps mais
j'ai regardé les chiffres d'épidémie est
arrivé au même moment en autriche le
confinement de la population a eu lieu
un jour près la même date le 15 mars
est-ce qu'il n'y aurait pas d'autres
pistes vous dit peut-être des
autrichiens qui respectent de manière
extrêmement stricte c'est ça qui ressort
en tout cas dans le pays pour la
réussite de cette stratégie
je ne pense pas que toi non plus le seul
critère
bon maintenant bon il a été décidé en
fait de la semaine dernière que
le pas le port du masque serait
obligatoire dans les supermarchés donc
donc avant la vie ça c'est une des
mesures aussi qui peut contribuer en
fait à endiguer en fait l'épidémie
non c'est vrai qu'on a vu dans des
reportages sur l'autriche des masques
tout simplement être distribués à foison
à toutes les personnes qui entraient
dans les supermarchés vous vous l'avez
vécu vous même cette distribution de
marche de masques pas redondant dans les
magasins oui effectivement bronze a eu
l'occasion d'aller faire les courses le
week-end dernier
donc on va effectivement fourni un
masque et se sont donc oui excusez moi
bon par contre dans c'est vrai que comme
cette mesure n'a été annoncée
il a été prévu que depuis le milieu de
la semaine dernière bon il y avait il y
avait encore des difficultés
d'approvisionnement et je suis allé dans
un autre supermarché où il y avait plus
de masques
mais bon depuis lundi en fait le port et
du masque est vraiment obligatoire dans
toutes les les supermarchés
depuis ce temps là je n'ai pas eu
l'occasion d'y retourner
donc je verrais bien la prochaine fois
s'il est si les mavs que sont bien
disponibles à toute occasion
comment les autres et chiens vivent
qu'ils cette séquence d'abord le
confinement et maintenant cette
stratégie de déconfinement qu'est ce qui
est dit sur place
je pense que le fait d'avoir annoncé des
mesures d'assouplissement a été un grand
soulagement pour tout le monde puisque
bon ça fait maintenant trois semaines
que nous vivons cette situation et même
si chacun essaye de tirer le meilleur de
la situation c'est quand même une
situation pesante
donc je pense que pour ça on peut pas
dire que les autrichiens le lit
forcément mieux que dans d'autres pays
voilà donc maintenant bomba attendons de
voir
si cette tendance se poursuit qui fait
justement que les chiffres de
l'infection les les chiffres d'infection
temps de ralentissement et que et après
bon ben il faut pas non plus trop
crédibilité des choses à mon avis est ce
que les autrichiens craignent cette
fameuse deuxième vague a dont on parle
souvent je ne pourrais pas dire ça mais
bon je pense que il reste prudent avant
tout est bon le gouvernement a bien dit
que il fallait ne pas trop se précipiter
bon le week-end dernier à une polémique
puisque le ministre de la santé avait
annoncé par erreur que les races les
rassemblements familiaux pourraient être
autorisées pour les fêtes de pâques
hébron ceci a été démenti le jour
d'après parce que ça avait entraîné
certaines conclusions dans la population
merci beaucoup pour votre témoignage
patrick badauds je rappelle vous êtes
les ont hués français vivante en
autriche depuis près de 15 ans merci à
vous